E  TO BE SURE,
THAT THAT MESSAGE WILL
REPORT.EY, VERY TE
YOU.
TRD FIGHT THE SSRERETURNIN THEIR
G TENNIS
JUSTO US.THANK YOSOATIDON 20SERI
UNFAMILY,  ANDT YOU  SAFETY TOOT
CA
I HA TS ANFE.
WHEN THIS HA.CATIOIN
I HAVE SEEN TH THERE.G AYT RUSS
UKE.
IT WAS NOT AN EASY DECISION.R ME
SIHICH WOULD
BE RIGHTY D
FEELUI TBACK.
AND NOW THAT I'M HL I'NOD YOURK
ATNIS EVENT,?
>>E DIDN'T TELL THEM AND I
DI WHERE I WASING WHEN I LEFT.SI
E THE OTHER DAUGHTERS  SON IS
FI
>>K, Y'RCING.U KNOW THE RISKS Y.
>>OW DID YOU HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION WITH YOUR WE?
SHE W.
AND SHE DIDN'T ACCEP
DESIFO A BETRAYAL.
UKRAINE NEVER GAVE ME SU MEDAL.
IT DOESN'T MATTEOMETHING
WATOBY MY COUNTRY.NDE BURIED HE.
HIOR MKID.D LIKE TO HAVE A
IF ITA ANDAINE
WOULD , THER A
E NOT EVEN IN THE
BOOKS.
WE TRANSFORMED
INTO H BOOKS
THE  HTOF UKULD BEE WHO UP TU DR
EL WE'VEOT BASICCLS.PLLIE WILL
TT THOBM EOORT.
E ARE I WOULD SAY HUNDREDSNTO FT
REPARE S
YOUR LE, LUEN
ICANSWER TO.T  THERE IS ONE INY
YOU NOW WHETHES READY TO
SACRIFICE LIFE.
.
I WANT TO SEE MY WIFE.
THAT'S MOM
MAYBE  TO.ISSILE ING
IS THAT ICE?
>> WHAT IS YOUR
OV.M
L BE OE
EUROPEE ANEV M TNS M